what's the one image that you associate
with Quakers or product yeah yeah why
are they associate that with Quakers
here's with one on the box right what
would be the second one it wasn't we
just open meal because there's there's
the guy I think there's a Liberty Bell
to add it isn't there should we can make
sense cuz Philadelphia maybe oil quaker
state oil wait your state is what state
pennsylvania right and it's named after
a very famous Quaker William Penn who
will talk about involved why are we
talking about these guys in terms of
being Quakers rather than the Society of
Friends is their official thing I mean
they don't mind if you ask somebody who
is in the Society of Friends you know
what's your denomination though quite
often say or worth Quaker because that's
what most people understand if they say
well we're friends you might think oh
I've got friends too that doesn't quite
make the same impact right they were
called quakers in part because they
would David said you know we're worried
about God they could hauled him to court
your book tells you you know one of
these little funny stories about this
they've been hauled into court for all
sorts of reasons and they wouldn't obey
the magistrate and that done you know
that was based up because nowadays if
you get held in contempt of court where
didya hope none of you have ever been
held in contempt of court but what looks
the most are going to do to you they'll
throw you in jail right that's what you
get for contempt of court may be fine if
it wasn't too bad that kinda could be
like a whipping or you know if they
threw you into jail back then it was not
like jails not jails back then we're
almost a death sentence in many cases
diseases your rampant conditions yours
horrible they know they can do all sorts
of things so these people say we're not
going to take our hats on in court that
was really taking a stand in the
magistrate
let me give you a chance take your hat
off or women time they wouldn't quite
say like that but you get the idea and
they would say no we're going to shake
or we're going to fear before God we're
going to quake that's what means to
quake is to to have the shakes to be
afraid yeah they would say you know you
ought to be afraid of God I'm not afraid
of you you're just a man destroyed
you're just a man you can't really do
anything to me that was very bold that's
where they're named King ones who are
literally afraid before cash or
something like that by the way for Jews
the herati literally means those who are
afraid before God those who fear dad so
the Quakers are coming out of the
English branch of the Reformation yeah
once the Reformation casteth just a
little bit of review we get the Church
of England right I'm from last class do
you remember who they're doing this was
a comic book through their big enemies
would be Church of England be like the
the Empire would be the rebellion
because of Star Wars terminology one of
the people I meet one of the groups of
people that we talked about before they
came over to get that get out of Dodge
is they never member very good so you
have a church of england on one side and
got Puritans aided and abetted by
Presbyterians and a few other thing on
the other side and eventually you
there's other things involved of course
you get a civil war and when a country
to develop devolves into civil war you
have a lot of chaos you know you can
think about what happened after the
invasion in modern-day Iraq are you
going very strong totalitarian regime
United States with
the Allies came in took him out and did
things go back to normal right away no
we're still not completely back to
normal there's different factions a lot
a lot of violence on sometimes getting
rid of one power structure it opens up
the door for a lot of chaos and that
doesn't just involve politics remember
these people at that time are very
interested in matters of religion so
your book costs about a number of
different phone sex arrival it gives you
some examples of some of the biggest
runs the ranchers who are pantheist that
means that they believe that God can be
found and everything the diggers who
advocated communal ownership of land on
religious grounds not going to fly with
traditional Anglican or Puritans they're
not gonna go for that muggle Tony ins
who claimed to be the two witnesses of
the book of Revelation the 5th monarchy
man who where I'm saying that the
Millennium is here we're going to talk
about millennial movements a little bit
later on when there's chaos quite often
people will come out and seen and say
it's the end of the world and walk and
they'll turn to we're called the
apocalyptic books of the Bible you know
and start talking about prophecies and
no people starting visions so there was
a lot of that going on at the same time
you also have people out there called
seekers he has seekers were interested
in trying to figure out which of these
are actually right or if none of them
right what would be right what would it
be authentic Christianity remember at
this time you now have a lot of
different competing voices it's not just
Protestants versus Catholics is
Protestants versus Protestants versus
other Protestants all of whom are
claiming that they are the ones who
really
how Christianity ought to be lived
thought about practiced organized so
that leads to people who you know in
philosophical terms you would call these
skeptics because it's the original
skeptics means seekers The Skeptical
those who are looking for something else
and if your listings for meaning
religious meaning in their lives maybe
some of you have had you know periods
like this in your life where you know
you grew up in one tradition you said I
had this really isn't doing it for me I
don't want to get rid of religion
altogether I want to find something on
the last should be suited to me how
might you do that well sort of things
could you what sort of means could you
could you pursue do you know any people
like that dude they're looking they
don't know they don't think they have
the answer yet but the internet was out
there what might you do that's a good
idea tougher doubt his travels kind of
expensive oh you know I was a college
student things were much cheaper it's
kind of sad for you guys because you
know you know the same opportunities in
many respects but that's a great idea
try out other cultures Rene Descartes
says that travel is as good as going to
school he's the you know he's a guy who
actually went to a lot of school he went
to university that's a law school
medical school and he says travel is as
good as reading books because he gets to
the customs of other people's you get to
try on their their way of life yeah and
my most of time of doing are surrounded
with art of the same cold
yeah yeah it's like it's like trying on
this is going to be kind of facetious
it's like trying on a new weighted
clothing right first it doesn't fit
really well like I don't know people
live like this but then after a while it
starts to feel comfortable you're like
oh it's nice to have pockets here I've
never had that this is a real advantage
and you know you can go on and on and on
we could make all sorts of in the ology
subjects but you're right one you know
in any religion it wouldn't be
necessarily going other countries if
you're going to other people's churches
I know quite a few people will go this
church on this this weekend this church
on this weekend and he asked me what are
you doing I'm looking looking for
something that will fit me how do you
know that it fits you though it'd be
awfully handy if there was like a sign
you know that you walk in ding this is
the church for you but that rarely
happens yeah yeah you would look for
whether you whether you find joy whether
you find peace whether you find all
these sorts of things that traditionally
people would talk about in Christianity
now this guy George Fox it's a shame
that the book was really talking about
his wife because he she was also very
important in this movement he's one of
these seekers like a book says he became
impatient with external forms of
religion began to teach that the truth
could be found most purely within each
individual including himself and he's
looking for something like that a kind
of response something that would would
say yes this is this is the right way he
talks about his followers and it also
talked about this sort of prophetic
incident where he's going into town and
preaching and eventually he thinks that
he's latched on to
something that makes complete sense of
I'm a key calls the inner light this is
still something very central to friends
or Quakers today this notion that
there's an inner light and I should I
should put this underneath inside
everyone every single person can be the
temple of God every single person could
have a revelation from God or the Holy
Spirit speaking within and now if you if
you if you have a sort of you like it
says in the text this light which is the
Holy Spirit of spirit of christ is the
ultimate authority in matters of
religious truth and is to be cultivated
followed by all friends and the context
of the meetings for worship so this is
sort of like remember how we talked
about the Pope you know with Catholics
is where the Box Tops if there's like
some sort of disputes I mean that's
traditionally the function of the Pope
is to say we're coming down on this side
it's not like he you know sits in the
Vatican and says what can I be
infallible about today I mean let me
think of something to talk about it only
happens once and a very long why that
he'll make some sort of important
pronouncement like that this is sort of
like each person being there all the pro
being you know God's emissary so this is
pretty revolutionary isn't you know
think about encouraging there you go out
of order and structure they decide we're
going to keep this they have bishops
imagine you were a bishop for a priest
at the time in the Church of England and
you've got these people who are going
around in your town and saying yeah I've
got this inner light it says that these
other guys are full of it and we don't
have to listen to them and they don't
know if their time
about when it comes to scripture or God
really we just eat you have to follow
our own individual life has got that's
how God is going to talk to us you might
not like that right you might say these
guys are trouble makers and that's what
he averaged I mean the Quakers were not
popular among Anglicans nor hmong the
Puritans nor month quite a few of the
other sex it selects about you know some
of the trouble that they got into some
of it was caused just by their
insistence on seeing everybody's equals
we don't use terms like I suppose wish
for this on as well via foul right vine
what else goes with that zhi dao 9 you
know why they use that at the time in
english as we teach it today we use a
different word for this right we use you
and that can be the object or the
subject you is actually the second
person plural in english we just use it
you know for everybody individual or
pork butt back in their day you would
address somebody who you knew quite
intimately with the second person
singular thee and you would address
other people more formally with you
that's why you caught on how many of you
have studied German or French I don't
know spanish has this sort of thing and
if you study French so it's like it's
like saying to to another person in
front you don't do that with anybody off
the street because they would they would
think that you're being rude other
certain classes of people you wouldn't
do that
if you are in a quart of water even if
you knew the judge you wouldn't use two
events in german it's dude right you
wouldn't use do i think they call it to
do tins like to tie in fresh you would
use here which is which is a different
program well it was the same way in
english so let's use DM val was very
informal very intimate to do this with
the authorities quickly asking for
trouble it'd be sort of like walking
into a quarter than saying hey judge
how's it hanging I don't do that in the
courtroom today because that would get
you in trouble it was all these sorts of
things this insistence on sort of
leveling distinctions on equality on
holding to individual judgment that the
10 as we get them in a lot of trouble
and that's probably a good good place to
sort of segue into why they wound up in
Pennsylvania so your book talks about
word fox and it also talks about william
penn and head is a concert he's a he's
not a Quaker originally but he becomes a
Quaker and it just so happens that he
holds some debts that the British
monarchy always and you know you could
buy a lot of things with debts but it's
kind of hard to to settle them you know
you said one want some ships or many
bales of cotton yeah when he says I'd
like this trap to land over here and
that's what we nowadays know his
Pennsylvania pretty big tracking of land
isn't head is his name so they is the
Latin word for forest so his pet is
forest and what he did is he said all
right the Puritans up north they're only
letting Puritans in and if you're if
you're not fitting in there you gotta go
over to Rhode Island and further south
you know it's all hang look-ins and
they're not treating other people
as well as they should either why don't
I create a spot where anybody can go
there won't be any established church
and it'll be safe for everyone to pursue
their own their own relationship with
with God that's what he did and he went
beyond that your book talks about him
going out two trips you know in Germany
the Rhine Valley where you had a lot of
these sectarians that's part of why the
Amish and Mennonites yeah some of these
other groups came to Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania was sort of like the Ellis
Island for non conformist Protestants
those who didn't fit in the Ellis Island
before Ellis Island and then from there
you know they fanned out into other
choices a lot of these smaller groups
went across the Midwest in Ohio and
Indiana now he talks about the text
talks about some of the issues that came
about a little bit later I want to
backtrack and focus on services have any
of you ever been to a a friends or
Quaker service no no watch yet you know
there is a very welcoming you might
think it's a little strange if you're
used to other kinds of religious
services because a good portion that you
might think they're actually you know
just meditating because it's quiet there
sitting some services it could go with
nobody saying anything what yeah hope
you know one of our friends she went to
UM Penn Charter in Pennsylvania and so
just a headache that every thursday for
school and she said that like God is
supposed to like speak to you and then
you say what like he wants you to say
yeah that's this notion of the inner
life and I mean you can see that maybe
this could lead to certain abuses if
somebody's you know given to claiming
that God is speaking to them
for the most part this doesn't turn out
to be a big problem if God says
something like I want everybody to give
me your wallets probably not guy right
what what they'll do is they'll wait for
a prompting of the inner light they'll
wait for God to speak to them and if God
doesn't speak during the entire service
well then you know try again next time
and still you know we'll go back and
forth this is also how they handle
business with them within the church
within the ecclesial community they try
to come to consensus on things they try
to talk things out you're very devoted
to to dialogue rather than conflict and
this this runs throughout their entire
ethics now to go back to Pennsylvania
one of the things that your book talks
about which is why there are different
groups of Quakers out there has to do
with adaptation to other other religious
groups in another dynamic to that we saw
with the Puritans if you're living a
kind of ascetic lifestyle you're not
spending a lot of money on you know
frivolous things like drink we remember
we just going out to the bars cost you
money if you want to be rich you can't
go to the bar all the time unless you've
already made it fresh we're not spending
a ton of money on clothes you're not
spending a ton of money on luxury items
and they work very hard so one of the
key areas that is you know we think of
Philadelphia we think of Liberty Bell
and Philly cheesesteaks and perhaps that
show it's always sunny
Philadelphia should i'm a big fan by the
way i probably shouldn't be totally
nihilistic philadelphia main city of
brotherly love auto focus brother kilos
means means love and Quakers or friends
were among the people who founded it and
you know what you found a city generally
end up being pretty important in the
city and quite a few of them ended up
becoming a fairly prosperous and your
book talks about some tensions that they
came about in this whenever you start to
get rich there's a tendency to you know
make distinctions between between people
you know better church pews in this case
like a book talks about they would wear
the same hadn't closed but some would be
made a much better material some some
less material in a one when you have a
case like that longing will come
somebody like Elias pics who's calling
for return to original wait for values
even think of this is like a reformation
within the Reformation and he emphasized
the inner life tradition which he
thought was being sort of downplayed and
left out as as the Quakers in
Philadelphia were becoming more and more
prosperous they were also starting to
look an awful lot more like the other
promises and they were looking less and
less like the original Quakers so like
it so this resulted in a split of the
Quaker community to Orthodox the older
ones and Hicks eight fashions now your
book also says this is only the
beginning other splits took place the
Quakers Philadelphia is is uh you know
it's right out of eastern seaboard
Pennsylvania law on state business
they're moving west and as they're
moving west this is a very important
dynamic
that we're going to look at not every
religious group or community transports
well you know what i mean by the when i
say doesn't transport law sort of like
you know beer and widen whiskey nowadays
we have great logistics it's easy to
transport anything anywhere you don't
have whiskey was such a big thing in the
Old West it was a one liquor that you
could actually transport that wouldn't
get shaken up so much and lose a lot of
its quality couldn't do that with beer
wine not so much either you know that's
why the group wine in California whiskey
you could transport certain religious
forms don't transport very well if you
need an educated clergy and you need
very structured church traditions that's
not going to be very easy to take out to
the American frontier a large part of
Pennsylvania was the American frontier
for four decades the Quakers along with
the Methodist Baptist they were the
people who were easy to take out there
because you know all you do is wait for
the inner light or preach the gospel or
you know those are going to talk about
the Methodists you know try to awaken
this this sanctification experience
that's pretty easy to take a long and
the takers found themselves getting more
and more like some of these other groups
so it led to another split the screen
those who are followers during those
were the followers of Wilbur and you
don't need to know that much about these
these particular guys as individuals
it's more what they represent gurnee
represented this this more evangelical
you know like the other denominations
like the Baptist like the Methodists
emphasis Wilbur was was once again sort
of like kick saying you guys don't lose
your roots don't lose what makes you
distinctive and Quakers started
splitting into different groups nowadays
there's like your book talks about there
three main groups and we'll talk more
about them in a later chapter and then
there's a few smaller groups there are
not many Quakers left they have not aged
well as a denomination but they were
extremely important in early American
religious history